Speaker 1: I want to give you a little sort
of chapter in the book about how extreme the
American right wing movement is getting.
There is this sort of like on campus right
wing group called Turning Point USA.
Charlie Kirk is one of the sort of more publicly
known people associated with this group, Turning
Point USA.
They have now jumped fully into this sort
of conspiracy.
Q Anon, Alex Jones fray to the point that
at a recent event called Defeating the Great
Reset, the Great Reset is a favorite idea,
I guess we would call it, of people like Alex
Jones and Steve Bannon and those types.
Charlie Kirk actually interviewed Alex Jones.
This was at one point sort of like I never
considered them this, but considered by the
right a very mainstream right wing group,
just indoctrinating college students into
basic conservative economics and this type
of thing.
It is completely over the hill insane at this
point in time.
And I'm going to play for you a clip here
of Charlie Kirk making a really big deal of
I mean, listen, after all, it's just Alex
Jones.
It's just a conspiracy theorist.
This is the great thinker that Turning Point
USA is bringing to its attendees.
It's it's sad, but also scary in that it shows
how extreme this movement has gotten.
Speaker 2: A special remote just for you.
Now, I only ask this since we're doing the
remote guest.
While I'm while we're talking, I just wanna
make sure our guest can hear everything we're
saying and all that.
So I was told by everybody.
It's not the President Trump, but it is going
to make you guys wait.
Do you see this?
All right.
Wow.
Speaker 1: Must be pretty good.
Speaker 2: In fact, this man is more hated
by the media than Donald Trump.
And that says something.
Okay.
Which is.
So if you're going to talk about the great
reset, right, then you have to have which.
Speaker 1: By the way, I don't know why you
would, but.
Speaker 2: Someone who is the most banned
man in America.
Alex Jones joins us.
Speaker 1: How exciting.
We're now going to get the truth.
Standing ovation to the guy who said something
about gay frogs and that Sandy Hook was fake.
Speaker 2: To Alex Wolff.
Alex, welcome remotely.
I was told by all the people like, Oh, you
can't have Alex at your event, which makes
me just want to have Alex even more.
Speaker 1: Anything that people say is bad
is actually good.
That's fundamentally conservatism.
Sometimes I want to be reactionary conservatism.
Sometimes things that people say are bad are
actually just bad.
Speaker 2: Alex, you wrote a book on the Great
Reset, the Great Reset.
Why did you write the book?
Speaker 4: Well, I saw Barry yesterday, and
he's absolutely right.
Speaker 2: And I love that, you know, the
title match.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: They are now including Alex Jones
in Official Turning Point USA events.
Here is what I hope you will glean from this.
These are considered the thinkers among the
right.
Here's one more clip where Alex Jones talks
about cows biblically.
Speaker 2: Let's let's zero in on the food
thing.
Alex, in particular, they are fascinated with
getting rid of meat.
Talk more about that, but also talk about
the other implications of getting rid of meat.
Testosterone levels maybe replacing with this
synthetic nonsense that Bill Gates just happens
to also be an investor in, by the way.
Super crony capitalist.
Talk about why they're so incredibly focused
on eradicating meat from our planet.
What's going on?
What's going on with us?
Speaker 1: Yeah, tell us.
Speaker 2: Well, if you go back to Genesis.
Anybody should go read it.
Written 3000 plus years ago by amazing Jewish
scribes.
Speaker 1: I'm so not anti-Semitic that I'm
going to call the Jewish scribes amazing.
Speaker 2: Inspired by God.
I mean, in the first chapter, they just keep
talking about cows and meat all day long and
saying, that's the real symbol of freedom.
Now, Moses said later, We're not going to
worship the golden calf.
That's a dollar tree.
But they were worshiping gold.
Speaker 1: Let's let this this guy is truly
pathetic.
And I want to tell you what the real scam
is here.
The real scam is this entire movement pretending
to care about the Bible.
We talked with Ben Dickson about this in the
last segment and he says these people aren't
even really Christian.
This was the moment at which point it became
clear that the five, six years that followed
were going to be Republicans pretending to
care about the Bible.
Speaker 2: Okay.
You mentioned the Bible.
You've been talking about how it's your favorite
book.
And you said, I think last night in Iowa,
some people are surprised that you say that.
I'm wondering what one or two of your most
favored Bible verses are.
Speaker 4: And I wouldn't want to get into
it because to me, that's very personal.
You know, when I talk about the Bible, it's
very personal.
So I don't want to get into I don't want to
get into.
Speaker 1: I mean, by the way, notice how
articulate Trump was, even just how much more
articulate Trump was even just a few years
ago.
Speaker 2: I got to you that you think about
or cite.
Speaker 4: The Bible means a lot to me, but
I don't want to get into specifics.
Speaker 2: Even to cite a verse.
Speaker 4: No, I don't want to do that Old
Testament guy or a New Testament probably
equal.
I think it's just an incredible.
Speaker 1: Are you a pancakes or a French
toast guy?
Both are good, but both are really good.
Speaker 4: The whole Bible is an incredible
job.
Very much so.
They always hold up the art of the deal.
Say my second favorite book of all time.
But I just think the Bible is just something
very special.
Speaker 1: It's super special.
And Donald Trump is not going to say any any
more about it.
These are the exact type of panders that Ben
Dixon was just warning about in the last segment,
who he
is fighting against.
Really
scary stuff.